LETITIA WRIGHT
Hey everyone.
DANAI GURIRA
We're the cast of Marvel Studios'...
DOMINIQUE THORNE
And today we'll find out which one of us...
TENOCH HUERTA MEJÍA
...knows our castmates the best.
LUPITA NYONG'O
And guess who's going to win?
LETITIA WRIGHT
I am.
LUPITA NYONG'O
Please.
ANGELA BASSETT
Let the guessing begin.
LUPITA NYONG'O
This person has an...
I know this answer.
WINSTON DUKE
You go.
DANAI GURIRA
ANGELA BASSETT
Dominique?
WINSTON DUKE
I'm going to go with Angela Bassett.
TENOCH HUERTA MEJÍA
Uh, Winston.
DANAI GURIRA
Letitia Wright.
LUPITA NYONG'O
It's Dominique.
LETITIA WRIGHT
'Cause she kept talking about it on set.
[Laughing]
RIRI WILLIAMS
To be young, gifted, and Black,
though, right?
LETITIA WRIGHT
This person has...
- Wow.
DANAI GURIRA
Tenoch.
LUPITA NYONG'O
It's definitely Angela Bassett.
WINSTON DUKE
Angela Bassett.
ANGELA BASSETT
I think that might be me.
DOMINIQUE THORNE
This has got to be Miss Angela Bassett.
LETITIA WRIGHT
I'm gonna say it's Tenoch.
LUPITA NYONG'O
Whoa!
TENOCH HUERTA MEJÍA
Angela Bassett.
Oh!
LETITIA WRIGHT
[Screaming]
LUPITA NYONG'O
You got me, man!
WINSTON DUKE
Oooh, that was good, you pulled away!
This person is...
DANAI GURIRA
What?
DOMINIQUE THORNE
Lupita!
DANAI GURIRA
What sort of doctor?
WINSTON DUKE
Has to be a PhD.
TENOCH HUERTA MEJÍA
Danai.
LETITIA WRIGHT
Miss Angela Bassett.
DANAI GURIRA
It might be me.
ANGELA BASSETT
Oh!
I am a doctor,
I have 5 doctorates.
LUPITA NYONG'O
It's true, though.
LETITIA WRIGHT
Right?
DANAI GURIRA
Don't hate the player!
M'BAKU
You bald headed demon.
RAMONDA
Show some respect, you two.
LUPITA NYONG'O
This person...
Well, it's not you, that's good.
TENOCH HUERTA MEJÍA
Uh, Winston.
ANGELA BASSETT
I'll say Letitia.
DOMINIQUE THORNE
Tenoch.
LUPITA NYONG'O
Can I guess?
LETITIA WRIGHT
Yeah.
LUPITA NYONG'O
I think it's Michaela Coel.
WINSTON DUKE
Letitia Wright.
DANAI GURIRA
I'm going to agree.
LETITIA WRIGHT
Who is it?
Thank you.
WINSTON DUKE
Woo!
LUPITA NYONG'O
[Gasp] Your poker face was amazing!
DANAI GURIRA
Come learn more about the
next chapter
of our characters...
ANGELA BASSETT
...in Black Panther: Wakanda Forever.
DOMINIQUE THORNE
Only in theaters...
DANAI/WINSTON
...November 11th.